اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
ثلاثه فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين برصاصه
قناصه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مدينه جنين
بالضفه الغربيه وقال شهود عيان ان
الاحتلال اطلق النار على شهداء الثلاثه
قرب الميدان الرئيسي لمدينه جنين بينما
دار اشتباكات مسلحه مع مقاومين فلسطينيين
وذكرت مصادر محليه ان قواتنا الاسرائيليه
خاصه تسللت الى المدينه ونشرت القناصين
الذين استهدفوا المراه ودفعا بدوريات
عسكريه وجرافات الى المدينه الى المخيم
كما تعرضت احداث سيارات الاسعاف لاطلاق
نار من قبل الاحتلال خلال محاولاتها
انتشاله احد الشهداء
وافاد مراسل الجزيره بين انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال من جنين بعد اعتقالها ضابطه امن
واسيرا محررا وشابا فلسطينيا
بمزيد من التفاصيل معنى من جنين مراسل
الجزيره سمير ابو شمالي اذن سمير مزيد من
المعطيات والمعلومات بشان ما حصل في جنين
[موسيقى]
سمير تسمعني
نعم صحيح اسمع الان
ضعنا في صوره الذي حصل والمعطيات المتوفره
برصاص جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيليه فجر هذا
اليوم في مدينه جنين والمخيم خلال هذه
العمليه العسكريه الاستاذ المناطق او
الاطراف
مخيم جنين وفي داخل وسط مدينه جنين في هذا
المكان بالتحديد نحن الان نقف عند ال ال
ال المكان استشهاد وموقع استشهاد الشبان
الثلاثه في هذا المكان بالتحديد هناك اثار
لدماء احد الشبان الشهداء الذين سقطوا في
هذا المكان كان هناك عمليه همم اغاثه من
قبل الشبان الفلسطينيين لبعضهم خلال هذه
العمليه العسكريه حيث كان هناك انتشار
لعدد من القناصه لجيش الاحتلال في ال
البنايات المحيطه في هذا المكان التي كانت
تنشط في قوات الاحتلال وذلك بهدف همم
اعتقال مطلوبين لدى قوات الاحتلال حسب بين
الجيش الاحتلال لحيته اعتقل احد الشبان من
منزله في هذا الموقع بالتحديد هناك عمليه
استنفاق قويه كانت خلال هذه العم العسكريه
من قبل المسلحين ايضا كانوا قد خرجوا
لتصادي لهذه القوات الاسرائيليه من جميع
الاذرعه التابعه لفصل ال- ال- الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
وكان هناك تصدي من خلالهم في اشتباكات
المسلحه ولكن الجيش الاحتلال لم يبلغ عن
وقوع اصابات بين صفوفه ولكنه قد اطلق
النار على عديد من المسلحين وايضا اطلق
النار على عدد من المواطنين المره اللذين
كانوا يتواجدون في هذا المكان بالتحديد
حيث كان هناك اعتداء للقناصه وتم قنص ال-
الشبان الثلاثه في هذا المكان وقتلهم في
همم هذا الموقع الذي كي تعرضوا لعدد عده
عيارات ناريه ورصاصات قد ايه هناك اثار
لهذه الرصاصه حتى في ال- همم في هذا
الطريق وقد تم قتله وتصفيتهم في هذا
المكان وجود سيارات الاسعاف ومواطنين
كانوا يحاولون انقاذ هؤلاء الشبان الثلاثه
الذين تم تصفيتهم في هذا المكان من قبل
القناصه الاسرائيليين الجيش الاحتلال في
هذه العمليه قد استهدف من خلالها وسط
للجنين حيث نخف وايضا اطراف مخيم جنين
وكان هناك عمليه اعتقال
لثلاثه مطلوبين لدى قوات الاحتلال حسب
بيان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذه العمليه
اسفرت حتى هذه اللحظه عن استشهاد ثلاثه
فلسطينيين وهما عطى شلبي وهو من سكان بلده
نقابات جنوب مدينه جنين وايضا صدقي زكارنه
وايضا شهيد الثالث وهو طارق الدماج من
داخل مخيم جنين في هذه الاثناء الانسحاب
كان قبل نحو ساعتين من هذه المدينه بعد
عمليه تصفيه الشهداء الثلاثه ترتفع حصيلك
الشهداء في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه وايضا
القدس المحتل بدايه هذا العام الى 215
شهيدا شكرا